(gentle music)
- All right, Balazs, it's
good to see you again.
- Hello, good to see you.
- I think last time
I saw you in Florida
was about a year ago and
you welcomed me to Budapest,
you said, come on over to
Hungary, and here we are.
- Thank you very
much for visiting us.
I hope you enjoy the weather.
- Oh, well, I mean, the
weather is incredible.
The view, obviously, from
up here is incredible.
People will probably hear
a little construction
in the background, we are
sitting right across now
from the old Red Cross building,
which is under construction.
And I thought that
would be a nice way
to start the interview
because there is a lot
of construction going
on here, I mean,
this is an old city
that is, to me,
feeling a bit like a new city,
so there's something
interesting going on here.
- Yes.
I would add two things, one
is that, you know, it's a,
construction is always a
sign of economic success.
So in general, if
you have construction
sites all over, you,
you know, probably, you don't
like them for a short period
of time, but for a
longer period of time,
it's like shows the economic
strengths of the country.
And I'm happy to see
that here in Budapest is,
and all around Hungary,
something is doing.
And the other part
is reconstruction
of the so-called
Buda Castle Hill and,
which was actually demolished
in the Second World War,
it was bombed by the Russians,
and then before that,
it was used for military
operation by the Nazis.
And then the Hungarian
communists, who
obviously occupied
the country, they also
did some serious damage.
And these used to be classical,
wonderful architectural
style buildings,
and we made the decision
to rebuild them.
It's like there is a
governmental program,
so if you come back in two
years' time, you will see
the entire cast here fully
recovered, everything
is rebuilding in beautiful
classical architectural style,
it's still the best,
it's right now, today,
is the one of the
best places of Europe,
but it's gonna be
really, really gorgeous.
- Yeah, and as you
know, I'm coming here
after a nine-day trip to Israel,
and one of the things
that I found there
is they're constantly in
this battle between old
and tradition and new and
technology and everything else.
It seems like something
similar is happening here,
that you guys are trying
to look back at your past,
figure out the good parts
to bring to the future,
but then also govern in
a somewhat sensible way,
which is pretty rare for
the West at the moment.
- You're not anymore
talking about architecture.
- No, we're not talking about,
well, we can if you want,
are they gonna be putting up
some modern buildings here?
- Oh, actually, but,
you know, this is,
from the architecture debate,
you can understand, actually,
everything, because what we
are doing here is that we try
to restore everything which
made Hungary great in the past.
And it's part of our heritage,
if we are not proud of that,
then what makes us Hungarians,
what is the purpose of our life?
So this is the important part.
And the other part is
you will see in the city
some other modern buildings
which were created
by foreigners, very
famous architects
from all over the world.
I think it gives
us pride as well
to bring them to Hungary
and let them to work here.
And we are fighting against
the modern concrete and glass.
I mean, just like nothing
special type of buildings.
If there is something
Hungarian in that, obviously,
it has to be a
high quality thing,
but has to add some tiny
little Hungarian thing in that,
this is how the things
are going to work.
And not only in just
architecture and reconstruction,
but like policy making, family
policy, things like that-
- How do you think those
things are connected?
Like architecture and
actually city life
and physically what
you're looking at
to the political side of things?
- I think that, you know, to
figure out what the people want
and what makes to be a good
government, it's not so hard.
Obviously, you can learn
about this for like years
in universities, but you get
the point very, very easily.
Like people want a safe
and beautiful environment
around them, people want a
very, a supportive environment
around them, a state which
helps them to raise their kids,
to make a family, to have jobs.
They want secure streets,
they don't want garbage
all around everywhere.
They want companies which are
producing high quality goods,
so it's so simple and you
are having good government
if you see that things
slowly, unfortunately,
but go into that direction.
If you look back
retrospectively,
it's obvious then where
you were 10 years ago
and what did you
achieve since then,
and if you see this
kind of progress,
not the progressive
ideology, then you feel
that something good
is happening, if not,
then you have to change
course because otherwise,
you're going down.
- What do you think the
secret to the success
of that has been in Hungary,
now, obviously, you're a rough,
you're a fairly small
country population-wise,
only about 10 million people.
So there's an ability,
it seems to me,
to direct those people
in a certain way where,
from an American perspective,
350 million people,
it's harder to herd those
cats and get them to see that,
we're seeing it at
the state level.
Since I've been here, we've
talked a lot about Florida,
you know, that's working, but
the national project seems
to be struggling.
- I think the most important
thing that you have
to be sure and make
sure that the people,
grassroot voters,
are behind you.
And then it doesn't matter
whether the media is
going against you,
whether the big corporations
are going against you.
In our case, as a small country,
international organization,
NGOs, and like Brussels
is going against us.
But if the people are
backing what we are doing,
then we are fine, this will
be always the last frontier,
the last, you know,
just place to stand.
- Do you find that people
like that, actually,
that the people support you more
when Brussels comes after
you or if you take a, say,
an immigration
policy that obviously
is counter to what the EU is
doing, that sort of thing?
- Honestly, among us,
I don't understand
why they are doing that, because
the more pressure they put
on us, the, the more popular
we are getting in Hungary
because it's obvious-
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, what happened in 2015,
400 people made the decision
to march across the country
without any kind of permission.
It's like not good, it's against
the idea of law and order,
people want to
have law and order.
So they said that they support
the government to stop it.
And since we have the attacks,
they support the government
even more, with a bigger metric.
It's actually not a
controversial issue politically
in Hungary.
Also, if you ask the
leftist opposition voters
whether they support
stricter immigration policy,
their answer answer
would be yes.
- So what is going on
with the left here?
It seems to me that
maybe it's not quite
as radical as our left,
is that fair to say?
I've asked a few people
that over the last day or so
and I'm getting
various, they wanna be?
- They want to be there-
- Well, that means they're not,
so it's probably
pretty good, yeah.
- That's it, excuse me.
- Well, you know, we
were talking about it.
I think the general
environment, it does matter, so,
and this is the reason
why the responsibility
of the media is big.
So I mean, it's like
politics is one issue,
party political debates
are part of democracy,
it's like, it's not about that.
But there is a common,
there should be
at least a common understanding
that, for example,
you do not support any
kind of violation at all.
And the media should not
support that, full stop,
this is based on common sense,
not based on party
political ideas.
And in Hungary,
I think the media
and even some serious
opposition parties,
they take it seriously
because they see,
if they go to another direction,
then the voters,
they will punish them
and they will not support
them anymore, they will look
for other alternative,
probably they will not vote
for Fidesz, but
they were looking
for new alternatives
on the left.
- Do you sense that-
- I'm happy to experience that.
- Yeah, no, I wish we had
a little bit more of that
with our left, it would
help bring balance-
- It's this fear
of radicalization,
you have to somehow
be able to stop it.
- Yeah, it's
interesting because,
from an American
perspective, our left,
they can have different
policies, obviously,
but there's something
else where they're angry
at the founding of the nation,
they're angry at the
laws of the nation.
That strikes me as much
more dangerous where-
- That's the thing when we
start talking about the LGBTQ
and the gender issues, and the
pope was here two weeks ago,
CPAC was here one
week ago, actually,
since the Pope was here,
that's when we have,
since then, we have
the good weather, so.
- [Dave] Yeah.
Well, then he did
something right.
- He did something.
And everybody was
very clear on that,
that this kind of gender
ideology, it's very dangerous
because it divides the nation.
So it wants to override
the idea of nationhood
and of that all the people,
it doesn't matter
what color they have,
how old are they,
where are they from,
they belong to the same
nation, and there is more thing
which unites them than
brings them separately.
So, and if you let these
ideologies emerge, then,
at the end of the day, sooner
or later, it takes years,
but it will destroy everything
which brings the
people together,
and then it will be
very hard to maintain
and to manage even the most
basic functions of the society.
- Yeah, it was interesting
because when I spoke last night,
I mentioned how, you know,
there should be a separation
between the LG and B
and T, that the T thing
is actually anti-LG and
B and it's anti-women.
And it got a nice round of
applause, which I was happy
to hear from a
conservative audience,
because I think that that's
an important part to note.
- True, but like, but also
in the migration issue
and with the, in general, with
the sexual minority issues,
obviously, discrimination
is not acceptable
because we are the same
society, all are human beings.
Any kind of sexual
discrimination is unacceptable.
Now, what we are doing in
Hungary is we try to focus
on what things are
bringing together people.
The wealthy people, the
not so wealthy people,
the young people,
the old people,
people coming from different
parts of the country.
And you have to
put a lot of energy
into convincing the
society that it's worth
to keep together, if we
have national purposes,
then we have to, you
know, keep united.
And I think this is what I
learned from the United States.
This is how your
wonderful country became
the most successful
country on Earth.
- Right, and interestingly, I
mean, the purpose of this trip
for me was to figure out
how do I import maybe
what is going on here back
into the United States,
because we seem to have
lost a lot of that,
what would be your main message?
I mean, you've been to
the United States a ton,
you were actually in Florida
just a couple weeks ago.
I mean, when you see some
of what's going on there,
what would be your main message
on how to fix some
of this stuff?
- Well, first of all,
we know our place.
So it's still a small,
small country far away
from the United States after
many centuries of suffering.
So how, you know, it's the
mouse and the elephant,
should I give an
advice to the elephant?
So I don't think that
it should be cured.
But our experience is that
people want to fix their life
and people want to
fix their country.
So, and it's not impossible
to bring them together
and be united, especially
in a democracy,
democracy is still the
best form to do so.
And all politicians who want
to restore American greatness
or do something against what
is going on right now there
should be aware
of the fact that,
if the people are behind you,
you have to convince them
to be on board with
you, and then you
will have the chance
to bring change.
- And do you basically just
ignore all of the noise?
I mean, the Prime
Minister's office
is literally about
30 feet that way,
I don't think he's in the
building at the moment but,
you know, when I tweet
that I'm coming here
or I retweet you, I get
a certain amount of,
oh, it's fascist
and they're mean
and blah, blah, blah,
and I look at it
and I then I just keep
meeting pleasant people
and seeing what's actually
happening on the ground.
But I mean, do you just
basically ignore the noise
and just go ahead?
- I mean, I would be surprised
if they were supporting me,
so that would cause us
more problem, I think-
- If the media was supporting
you, that would, yeah,
that's what DeSantis says also-
- Would support us.
- Yeah, well, it was a
pleasure seeing you again
and I look forward to
exploring just this absolutely,
tell me one, yeah, give me
one thing that we should do
if we have a little
fresh time today.
- This is the Hungarian
Empire Parliament Building-
- Absolutely stunning.
- It's a gorgeous,
gorgeous thing,
but it's about
Hungarian sovereignty
because it was built more
than 120-30 years ago.
And back at the time,
there was a competition
among the architects
that what kind
of building should be built.
And there was a commission
which made the final decision.
And as you see, this is
the only neo-Gothical style
of building in town,
all the other ones
are just now neoclassical and
neo-Renaissance buildings.
And back at that time,
the commission was saying
that it cannot happen that the
Hungarian Parliament building
will have the same
architectural style
as the Vienna
government buildings
because they were
neo-Renaissance buildings.
So that's the reason why
they went to that direction,
because they wanted to
have an independent,
a different, a
sovereign decision,
so they were choosing this kind
of neo-Gothical
architecture style,
there are no other buildings
with this style in the country,
this is the only one,
and this is like,
even 130 years ago, the
most important thing
for Hungarian people
was sovereignty,
how they differentiate the
Hungarians from Vienna,
which was the headquarter of
the empire back at that time.
So if you come to Hungary,
you will see a lot
of tiny little signs,
people for like 1000 year
or even more fighting
for their sovereignty.
And this is, if
you see the result,
this is a fight which
was to be continued.
- And on the continuing
path, you will also see a lot
of cranes because there's a
lot of new things going up.
So that proves it
right there, right-
- Is the basilica, which
is the main church,
the parliament building,
and the soccer stadium.
So these are the-
- It's all here.
- This is a triangle.
- It was great to
see you, my friend.
- Very nice to see you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlist,
all right over here.
(gentle music)
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.